horses passions I picked off
[Music]
Jan who kissed time to go David sighs
Doug Flynn was not gonna have his
shot-blocking versus train young to the
basket floating gun off glass on the run
Trey young gifted strong with the
basketball certainly stronger than he
looks
you can see plenty of contact there good
balance and concentration
[Music]
[Applause]
walks down deep decided to settle
themselves a bit offensively down
condition
turn it up defensively Trey Young gets a
shot off a screen that sticks it that's
incredible I got a little bit more four
out of five four chance reg impressive
again two out of two at that free-throw
line
Parker escapes Jabari Parker Jam shoot a
lot of mid-range stuff Parker with a
rebound Jabari Parker on the run
[Music]
outside the Freya and heat
now they're from behind the long line
opening night at Little Caesars arena
this is trim get it up and down the
floor and they take the first available
shot not the first necessarily good shot
right there
right to the wreck for a store 3f 14 to
play in the first
yeah with that crossover and a drive and
another deuce allows for one-on-one play
with Trey young is exploiting right now
the way downtown Gila 321 - and 20 left
in the first five out of eight behind
the long line for the hawk there is rose
three - an intruder
look out there he goes again the rim
just laying without Blake Griffin the
first five or six games anyway of the
season but way downtown for a young
buries it
that's the thing you know you he's got
your attention because he's popping from
way deep don't give up from penetration
as a result but he's hot the way beat
you got to get out there on it they're
growing to the stage why he buries it
Derrick Rose Humphrey was on us now
Parker's test out these scores of a
Jabari Parker born in 24 to play in the
half
[Music]
for Bruno Fernando and a score and
shield the defense away from Derrick
Rose but I'm mostly sure Rosie defeated
this and that was a great shot by
Jarrett young bumped outside and still
triples in that great rookie season but
what he's done in this first half of the
seasons arena has really good nothing
short of spectacular
well he's in the zone right now I mean
right now this is we're about to take
the lead
good and now the Hawks are scored eight
straight there is Rose off the girl
grains of dude Tony Snell for the
Pistons working outside use it up the
derrick rose against the andre memories
Derrick outside gun go about two and a
half seconds difference shot clock to
game clock back left of six for Derrick
Rose
Galloway [ __ ] three
with 3.4 seconds to play in the half
penetrate issues in the corner to Tony
Snell 53 rebound hurt her - Trey young
young Hobson jammed by DeAndre hunter
the rookie from Virginia a Snell coach
awry and this is what it allows Atlanta
running with numbers easy over to tabla
from young 43 in over 2 months there it
grows in the basketball game didn't take
long for him to deliver
he had 17 were tied at 71 when she did
gala with a pair of free throws he has
eight were tied at 73 five minutes to
play in the third praying out with a law
long gun it go interior people are
getting opportunities now because the
pistols continue to have to respect in
at risk for young Derrick Rose
unstoppable
Gary's Rose nice crossover here's the
jumper Wow Derrick Rose against Ramon
loading doors for Derrick Rose there is
rose against Humphrey Andre screens
offensive the on Drake gets away spray
up Humphrey yeah and Atlanta leading 105
to 92 they've now scored seven straight
points brea keeps that dribble dishes to
febri and DeAndre Bembry was a big-time
basket really the shots the different
England allowed the tape by Atlanta his
defensive last five ministers been
really really good that young with the
hoop they needed young now with 33 I
think that right there George is a
direct result of what just happened on
the offensive end for the Pistons that
came away him